[Music]
[Applause]
the heisman trophy winner from 2007 espn
college football analyst for the sec
network tim tebow back on the program
joining us on behalf of allstate good to
see you again tim what sport was tougher
to give up
football or baseball
that's a good one first of all good to
see you again it's been too long
honestly both of them were difficult i'd
say depending which part of the year it
is around thanksgiving christmas it's
really hard not to be playing football
and around you know in the middle of
spring when spring training is going on
that's really difficult not to be you
know in the middle of spring training
but
just love both of them loved all the
opportunities i got um you know in both
sports right you know being able to not
just pursue a dream but then live it out
in the moment um even when people are
like how are you living how was driving
17 hours in a bus a dream but
you know what it really was and that
might not have been the best part of
that dream but it's just awesome
opportunity so grateful for it tougher
to play
quarterback in the nfl or they hit a
baseball
now dan that depends who's pitching okay
if jacob degrom is pitching oh it's
definitely harder to
no play listen i got to face uh you know
jake
gosh
you know
six or seven times probably and
uh you know
even then when you would get a weak fly
ball or a ground ball you'd be like all
right
i'm out but it's not too bad you know
uh
toughest defense you faced
this steelers were really good defense
the um erlacker and briggs in that group
for the bears those were those were
probably two of the better ones um
the the jets in 11 with rex ryan those
are those probably three of the best
defenses i've faced probably i mean that
pittsburgh d
steelers team we faced in the playoffs
they had one of the best you know
historically good statistical defense
james harrison troy palamalu all those
guys that was they were ridiculous what
did they say to you any anybody give you
agree is there more trash talking in
baseball or football for you
football no doubt no doubt um oh yeah
they give you a a lot of grief i mean
some of the and some of them are really
clever you know like i give some of the
people
credit because it's like you would hear
the same stuff a lot you know like you
know we're coming at you today and you
know it's um you know you it's sunday
you better say some new prayers today
[Laughter]
you know he's like wow that's really
good and i would even sometimes
sometimes praise them for their trash
talk i'd be like dude i've never heard
that that was really good like it
sincerely made me laugh you know
and don't try to praise them but what i
also felt like is would you when you
would praise their criticism of you it
would be so disarming like sometimes i
would even get a oh thanks
they would tell me how they came up with
it you know like i was thinking about
that at thursday after practice well
at least you weren't thinking about how
to stop us so that's good you know
we're talking to tim tebow where is your
heisman trophy right now
oh goodness um
it is well it just left luke bryan's
house it was their
luke bryan the country singer yeah for
the probably the last maybe eight nine
years every year or every six months
i've used it to auction off for a
charity for people to keep in their
homes and use it as something that they
can i don't know brag about so luke
bryan
him and his wife
and caroline who are so sweet um they're
a big big part of some nonprofits that
we work together and so he he and his
wife won it and so then leading up to
florida georgia because he's such a
georgia fan like he would put a giorgio
jersey on it he would put peanut butter
all over it let his dog lick it off
he would
he would do all sorts of stuff i was
like this isn't fair right
he's trying to
you know hurt my husband so i i worked
with his wife to get one of his um cma
artist of the year awards which is uh
you know kind of a unique looking award
and so i started getting that and then
sending him videos of me using it as
like a you know a sparkling water opener
or you know
a jack for a car being able to lift it
up and so we kept going back and forth
and i think the cmas got kind of upset
with it i didn't actually hurt it it
just you know looked like we were using
it that way carson palmer joined us and
i asked him where his heisman was he
says it's in the garage
and i said well
why don't you send it to me he goes all
right
so he packed it up and then sent it to
me for a year and i had it in here
because he didn't even have it on
display
oh carson come on you got he the thing
that's awesome is it's such a cool it is
such a cool award that is so prestigious
that very few people have ever had the
chance to to be around it and you know
i'm so grateful dan i've had you know
with all the charities we've supported
it's been able to raise well over a
million dollars now
and
like and just to why have it in your
garage when it can be in someone else's
living room and now a lot of kids are
being helped with it and you know my
goal with that is that it could be the
most impactful heisman one day not by
you know sitting on a shelf and us
looking at it by
you know being on a lot of other shelves
and making an impact in a lot of kids
lives so carson come on we got to get
yours in some auctions for some kids no
it's a wonderful gesture on your part
because you would think you would want
to hold on to that and you know keep it
in a safety deposit box or whatever
but well i gotta i gotta tell you how
this idea started so we're at this um
this gala for um for for soldiers who
have lost their lives in battle and
we're coming together raise money for
their kids to give them scholarships in
greenwich connecticut and so you know
that's a wealthy area and there's all
these wealthy people and
nick saban has an auction up there
and you know what i hate losing to coach
chapin in alabama it only happened once
and it was one of the worst days of my
life and so i'm thinking you know what i
want to help but i also got to beat
coach chaban right you know like we we
got to beat him in this option
so it's like you know what what are
these i mean these people have
everything in the world what's something
they don't have and i was like oh i
don't think a lot of people had a
heisman
[Laughter]
certainly not in greenwich connecticut
they're not a lot of heisman winners
there in greenwich connecticut and so i
walk up there to tell the host
i said hey do you you think it would be
okay if i um
auctioned off my heisman or if you would
auction off my heisman for a year or
something he looks at me like
what yeah that'll be okay and so uh we
did it and uh actually kathie lee
gifford won it there
oh that's great
who else has had your heisman
um
well
everybody else that's had it you
wouldn't know
just supporters of the charity but those
are the kind of two more well people
that have won it
well-known people that have won it so
it's kind of funny how did you
you know
kind of
i don't know if it was your family how
you grew up but being philanthropic
you know it's it's something that you
seem to have embraced
for a while now
well i think it was um had a huge um
impact on my life the way that we grew
up having the chance to be born and grow
live the first five years of my life in
the philippines and um you know to
missionary parents that you know my dad
is one of my biggest heroes because he
spent his entire adult life helping
people that could never do anything for
him and being able to see my mom you
know just love people and
i mean looking back on my whole life
it's very rare if i could even think of
one or two instances she ever said
something negative about somebody else
you know and and i think that had such a
massive impact and then you realize that
you know there's a lot of things in life
that are um
that we can that can feel like
everything and so monumental in the
moment but ultimately
you know these these trophies and these
championships and everything they're
awesome but ultimately they're not
what's most important there's so many
things that are more important and i'm
so grateful for that perspective because
i'm someone that can totally lean
towards
win at all costs do whatever it can the
drive to compete and win and win
and i'm grateful for you know that other
side that you know helps me gain
perspective on what really matters and
never never lose trying to lose sight of
it because it can happen so easily and
so fast and you know my parents have
just been such an impactful um you know
purpose-led um you know
heroes in my life that i'm just so
grateful for
there's two job openings right now
nebraska and arizona state
if urban meyer asked your opinion
which job would be better
when i go nebraska
because
because you have one of the best fan
bases in college football
you have
the ability there to raise money and now
with the nil and college football that
even though it's not the best recruiting
base you can nebraska still has a pretty
well known
name
and you can be able to rally that fan
base to be able to go get some of the
players you need
i think arizona state is actually a
pretty good job so it's not a knocked
arizona state's job i think it's a good
job there's a lot of athletes in that
area you talk about the scottsdale
chandler you know that phoenix area
there's some athletes you can go get i
mean you look at all the quarterbacks
that are playing right now in the nfl or
in a college quarterback they're right
from that area spencer rattler is one of
them you know that they've never been
able to keep their at home jack miller
florida another one so they got to be
able to keep some of those guys at home
but
i just think to tradition and
uh you know i had the chance to you know
do a few events with coach osborne in
nebraska and to see the way those fans
rally they love their team they want
their team to win they're gonna support
it's one of the best fan bases not to
mention they're also probably one of the
nicest but i just think if they got
someone like an urban they got someone
that i think he could rally it very fast
and i think you could get more players
than maybe
a lot of other places around the country
how does it help you if it does florida
would play cupcakes and
you know i don't know what you get out
of playing a team that you're going to
beat by 50 points
besides giving them like 500 000 yeah or
a million yeah
um
it's it's not something that i really
liked um i
either my least favorite games i love it
when we see the alabamas and the texas
and i think we're going to see more of
that especially with the 12 team playoff
coming here in a couple years they're
going to figure that out but whenever
that does come i think you will see some
ads and presidents start to adjust the
because they're going to realize the
more that we reward teams for playing
hard big games early in the year and
then they get rewarded at the end of the
year for doing that i think the more the
aeds will continue to do that i think
that needs to happen i think it's better
for for a college football a game that i
love so much and and i think also the
players want to play in it you can't
tell me they want to play in some of
these cupcake games they don't right
they want to play they want to go to
austin and they want to play in that
game they want to play in atlanta to
start the season you know georgia and
oregon they want to play in those games
i think the fans want to see it as well
so i'm in favor of that you interested
in coaching
i love coaching i love
mentoring i love helping i love taking
what you've been able to learn and being
able to apply it to the next generation
i'd say the reason that college coaching
isn't quite as appealing to me
is because
it is so much more than a full-time job
you can't just say oh i'm gonna you know
be a college coach and then i'm gonna do
x y and z and for me i'm so fortunate
you know to be able to do a lot of
things that i'm so passionate about you
know uh my foundation being number one
of you know bringing faith open love to
those needing a brighter day in their
darkest hour need now we're fortunate to
serve in over 70 countries around the
world um you know i couldn't do that and
still coach and it's just so much so
important to me and so
i uh while i would love the thought of
coaching and you know there's been some
fun opportunities that have been
presented i just
i can't i don't feel like i could give
up the rest of that
are the arms bigger than they were when
you played
i don't think so i don't think so um
you know probably probably about the
same size
i don't know looks like maybe
definitely definitely not bigger than
the jets i got too big there
okay
the wildcat did you know that you were
going to be photographed with your shirt
off that one day in the rain
with the jets
do you know how many days after practice
we would stay and do stuff extra on the
side fields and run and everything else
you know and i mean that was you know
florida denver everywhere else i would
go we would go in back fields and we
would we would run and we would train
and some of my favorite things i would
even have string coaches come out there
after practices that's just the only
place that they will get back to back
fields to be able to film you and that's
probably what you know my lack of
awareness to say hey you are they're
gonna
you know
it was it was never something that you
were quite like okay this is this is
just private this is what they're doing
over there you know and um yeah but the
rain and uh i know but it just sends off
such the wrong message you know yeah
yeah it almost looked like you know they
had it in slow motion so when you were
running they i'm sure some people
probably did like baywatch you know when
uh pamela anderson won't run on the
beach which is exactly what i was going
for
uh what are you doing with affleck
well it's actually allstate but
also yeah
oops
i fumbled it my bad
hey
we'll edit that out hey what are you
doing with allstate
no it's so it's honestly it's one of my
favorite things to be a part of because
the uh the allstate good works team is
um a good work scene that honors 22
amazing young athletes and one honorary
coach 11 from the fbs and then the other
11 made up from the the fcs division two
division three naia and and dan there's
so many awards and championships and
trophies that all these young men get
for what they do on the field but this
is one of the few things that honors
them for what they do off of the field
and you know so many young men are
making differences in their community
and their their city states but honestly
even around the world and it's really
cool to be able to see and you know some
of these guys what they're doing is
incredible and so this i'll say afca
good works team is built up of amazing
young men doing amazing things in their
community and i mean you talk about what
some of these big
these guys are doing you know one of
them stands out to me is big man big
heart
you know an offensive lineman from fsu
is that's what his charities call big
man big heart he raised over you know
205 000
um you know for kids with leukemia and i
mean just it's over no andrew carlson
for auburn the kicker they've had
carlson's there for about 40 years
kicking and um you know it's so cool
he's doing mission trips in the dr caleb
williams quarterback at usc he's on the
team and you may be the most
recognizable but what he doesn't
actually get recognized enough for is
his caleb kara's foundation um you know
and making a difference in anti-bullying
and so it's so amazing to to see what
these these guys are doing and
doing to give credit to coach stoops
he's an honorary coach and not only is
he doing an unbelievable job at kentucky
with the you know their program and just
being probably the best of all time in
that organization but then you know we
he doesn't get credit for is the
millions that he's donated and done and
rallying people for their hospitals it's
really cool so that's what the good
works team is all about you visit
espn.com
allstate to meet this year's roster i
have that home run bat that you sent me
is that the bat
that you hit your last home run
i don't know if that was the last home
run but it was a home run yes okay
because i like i feel bad why don't okay
but you know like you loan out your
heisman
like i just want to make sure you don't
go hey anybody want the home run bat the
last home run i hit in the minor leagues
no it's okay you need it you have it if
you want it you keep it there and
yeah okay all right every now and then
you want to take some cuts just take
some cuts
i don't think you want me in the cage
with that back
it won't last long uh so tim tebow
joining us on behalf of allstate visit
espn.com allstate to meet this year's
roster great to have you back thank you
thanks for sharing these stories and uh
great to see you again great to see you
a blessing to see you man that's uh tim
tebow